You know, the most important thing in this job
is knowing you can trust the guy next to you.
No one does it alone.
One of my men is missing.
I think he is in a prison called "Hades".
What is this place?
- Land of the dead.
Everyone in this zoo has information worth millions of dollars.
Spies, criminals, businessmen...
We're all animals here.
That's why they call it "The Zoo".
And I'm the zookeeper.
Welcome to "Hades".
What makes you think he's there?
His cousin Yusheng is putting on some kind of hitlist.
Then we gotta go in, get him out.
I have this acquaintance, friend of mine...
Big guy...
I want in.
- Then we made a plan.
Sounds familiar.
Freeze!
I sure hope you know what you're doing.
I like working from the inside out.
Know layer...
Know the routine...
And you have help.
Get all in one and help get him out.
This is bigger than any one of us.
Showtime.
All the guys in "Hades"...
Time is up!
Hey, Breslin, good to be back?
No, it's bad to be back.